[Applaudissements]
merci d'être avec nous il est 20h44 je
ne sais pas s'il encore encore du twist
ce soir si vous nous rejoignez nous
sommes en direct allez on va faire le
point sur Jad enjy euh à l'idée avec
Myriam grand rera myiam Palomba elles
vont faire 7 à 8 dimanche on a quelques
infos déjà sur cette vidéo cette
interview inédite euh regardez c'est
vrai que tout le monde tout le monde
s'intéresse c'est les stars absolu Jad
et Joy son raort connu ce sera la
première interview de Jad et Joy ALID
qui se sont confiés à audre Crespo Mara
dimanche à 19h15 dans l'émission 7 à 8
elles raconteront leur vie à Los Angeles
et évoqueront la mémoire de leur père
elles avaient envie d'en parler à sur la
journaliste qui a raconé qu'elles
étaient tout de même très stressé au
début de l'interview déjà parce que
c'est leur première interview à la télé
mais aussi parce qu'ell pense autant en
anglais qu'en français allez faites-moi
twister alors c'est quoi l'histoire
bonsoir alors c'est assez exceptionnel
parce que c'est la première fois que j'
déjà ils vont parler à la télé ils vont
donner une première interview donc ça
c'est c'est c'est une exclu 7 à
donc en fait elles vont elles vont
parler donc pardon voilà elles vont
parler elles vont parler dimanche à
Audrey crispomara pendant 28 minutes
c'est un entretien assez exceptionnel
alors à ce qui paraît et effectivement
c'est le cas il y aura aucune question
tabou elles vont toutes les deux se
confier sur leur vie à Los Angeles sur
leur vie évidemment elles vont parler de
leur père et de la et de la comment
s'appelle de l'exposition qui va avoir
lieu là à Versailles le 22 le 22
décembre qui suit et puis effectivement
elles vont également parler de leurs
frères et sœurs à savoir Laura et et
David et sur cette histoire d'héritage
qui selon les maintenant 15 15 et 19 ans
ouais quand même ah ouais oua ça pousse
oui ça pousse et du coup elles vont
elles vont selon selon Dr Crespo Mara
elles expliquent que ça leur a fait
énormément de pine de cette guerre
d'héritage et que du coup du coup elles
vont pour la première fois s'exprimer
sur ce sujet ce qui est une assez
exceptionnelle et une exclu de 7 à elle
sera là latitia alors il y a pas
Laetitia alors c'est ça qui est qui est
assez sympa c'est que elle a décidé de
laisser ses filles'exprimer toute seule
c'était c'est c'est elle qui a décidé de
le faire et en même temps si elle avait
décidé de de de rester la la la
journaliste l'aurait viré hein c'est ce
que a expliqué audreé crispomara elle
voulait pas elle V pas que leur mère
vienne perturber l'interview et puis ce
que l'on sait ce qui va être aussi assez
rigolo c'est que Jade Jo qui évidemment
vivent à Los Angeles depuis des années
vont s'exprimer dans un peu elles ont eu
beaucoup de difficultés à s'exprimer
rigol bah ouais bah oui moi je trouve ça
rigolo elles vont elles vont elles vont
s'exprimerouis frlais
voilà mais c'est
voilà ça fait un peu miafille enfin bon
moi ça M fait marer non vous l'avez vu
j'ai j'ai vu de petits elle voit tout ou
c'est vrai qu'il y a une question qui se
pose sur le rôle de laticia parce que
dans toute la COM qui est faite on
insiste sur le fait qu'elle n'était pas
là qu'elle n'a pas influencé les
réponses et il y a des gens qui se
demandent si ce serait pas justement une
opération de Come menée par laetia pour
vendre encore plus de produits parce que
là on va fê l'anniversaire de la mort de
Johnny bah c'est c'est après c'est sûr
que laticia elle adore 7 à 8 elle avait
donné une interview il y a en 2020 je
cro le 8 à 8 aussi je l'ai vu faire ses
courses là-bas voilà elle avait donné
elle adore et et c'est vrai que pour
avoir interview les l'équipe de 7 à
ont vachement démarché l'entourage de
lticiaass
aussi et que du coup voilà mais après ce
qui explique audre crespomara c'est que
les elles sont assez indépendantes elles
sont plutôt intelligentes c'est ce
qu'elle nous dit moi je les connais pas
personnellement les adore et et que du
coup elles ont pas besoin vraiment de
leur mère pour dire ce qu'elles pensent
alors elles sont très suivies est très
suivi a 180000 personnes qui la suivent
sur insta et Joy 60000 personnes on va
Leser voir on va voir leur insta voilà
donc ça c'est ça c'est bah ça c'est jade
ça c'est jade si je ne m'abuse parce
qu'il y a marqué jade je vois sur son
poignet il a marqué jade euh merci bah
c'est bon on l' vu merci ça c'est c'est
Jo 15 Joy Joy non c'est jade c'est ça
c'est jod alors justement elles vont
elles vont réagir aussi sur toutes les
critiques qu'elles reçoivent moi mais
moi je trouve qu'elles font ce qu'elles
veulent non mais sans rigoler mais là
elles vont en parler parce que c'est
vrai que sur les réseaux sociaux vu
leurs tenue et cetera elles reçoivent
pas mal de critiques donc là pour la
première fois elles vont s'exprimer et
ce sera pas leur maman qui s'exprimera à
leur place toutes les jeunes filles font
des photos comme ça et parce que c'estjà
des j franchement elles font ce qu'elles
veulent moi je moi je moi moi je les
adore je les trouve d'ca je trouve
qu'elles ont un truc hein je pense que
elles sont très sympathiques Jade et Joy
donc elle donc elles reviennent et donc
on va les voir dimanche soir voilà on
les voit pendant 28 minutes elles
confier
tu nous feras un débrief avec plaisir
alors de son côté il y a il y a laura
Smet ah oui qui est hyper énervé qui est
hyper éner hyper vénère contre
Jean-Claude Camu parce qu'on on va voir
Jean-Claude Camu il est revenu sur les
différentes rumeurs concernant la mort
de Johnny c'était chez Jordan de luxe le
sémillan non je crois qu'il a des des
des des des prises de position souvent
inattendu et compliqué et compliqué et
que voilà exactement alors donc Johnny
par exemple ou Sardou pouvait dire ce
qu'il peuvent pouvait dire ce qu'il
voulait et cetera on leur paronner tout
à yanck on lui pardonne rien si vous
aviez un conseil à lui donner vous lui
diriez quoi à Yannick Noan ne prends
plus position bah je je laisse faire
assez avec d'autres oui oui
tais-toi ferme ta gueule et
chante c'est pas le bon extrès hein
c'est souvent le cas ici euh c'est quoi
le bon extr alors le le le le il est
revenu encore une fois sur le fameux
épisode où David et Laura n'auraiit pas
pu assister enfin dire une dernière fois
au revoir à leur père avant qu'il Meur
donc lui dans dans dans chez Jordan il
en avait déjà parlé il dit que c'est pas
vrai que c'est pas du tout comme ça que
ça s'est passé et que la vérité vraie
c'est que ce sont les infirmières qui
ont
refusé que Laura et David voi le leur
père et que c'est même Johnny qui a
refusé que il vienne le voir une
dernière fois contrairement à ce que
Laur et David disent David et Laura
disent que c'est latia qui les a empêché
d'assister de venir dire au revoir une
dernière fois à leur père qu'est-ce
qu'il veut non mais c'est vrai qu'elle
est très remontée parce queelle dit stop
au
mensonge elle est remonté com comme un
coucou oui parce que en fait elle dit
que Jean-Claude Camu ment et réécrit
totalement l'histoire alors qu'elles
étaient là dans le salon et lui il
s'arroge le droit comme ça de commenter
ça va c'est rien de grave arrêé ah non
mais ça leur a marqué av ils ont pas
direir lere mais la vérité c'est c'est
ça qui leur fait certainement hein ah
non rien c'est ça qui leur fait
certainement très mal c'est que
finalement c'est ni Laetitia ni vraiment
les médecins c'est Johnny qui était à ce
moment-là très très mal n'avait pas
envie qu'on vienne le voir d'ailleurs
Laura et et Nathalie ba était venu le
voir quelques jours avant lui avait
envoyé un sms pour venir le voir et il
avait et il avait refusé qu'elle vienne
et David c'est pareil mais pour David et
et Laura c'est très dur à entendre et
puis en plus ce qu'il reproche c'est que
finalement ils ont été prévenus de de la
mort de leur père une 1 heure après
qu'il décède et ils disent même que
laetia a appelé l'Élysée avant de de les
prévenir eux et que eux s'ils ont été
prévenus c'est grâce au médecins qui les
a appelé même pas laetia qui est venu
les voir donc pour eux c'est vraiment
traumatisant une curieuse méthode merci
en tout cas d'avoir été avec nous demain
vous revenez parce qu'il y a beaucoup de
choses à voir qu'on n pas pu voir ce
soirment il y a des trucs importants il
y a Nicolas bedo Stéphan Plaz qui son du
silence et Verdes qui rentre dans le
silence
meilleure nouvelle on passer